what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel mcu and
spider-man and today we have really good
news for fans everywhere this isn't like
the other day where we talked about an
event that only some people could go to
this time it's not like that at all the
trailer is going to be released online
for everyone to see and i know what
you're wondering when and what time
that's what we're going to be talking
about in this video and of course if
you're new and you want to stay up to
date on spider-man no way home be sure
to subscribe and also subscribe to my
channel and cosmic culture so you can
enter for a chance to win this
spider-man collectible just subscribe to
both channels and leave some comments on
some recent videos now the other day we
announced that there's going to be a
spider-man fan event in la on tuesday
tomorrow sony and marvel studios did
confirm that they were indeed going to
be showing the trailer at this event in
fact that's pretty much what the entire
event was for they also said that they
would have some big surprises in which
some people say we don't really know
what that's going to be but i think a
lot of people are assuming that at least
tom holland is going to be there and
maybe zendaya and jacob battle on with
him now this is great news and
everything for the couple of hundred
people who can attend that event but
what about everybody else well don't
worry it's going to be coming out
tomorrow and this is officially from
sony they posted today on twitter one a
new poster that i do say is better than
the last one and if you take a look at
the right hand side you can still see
the green goblin there but what's more
important is what they said in the tweet
trailer tomorrow spiderman no way home
is exclusively in movie theaters
december 17th so the trailer is going to
be online for everyone to see tomorrow
now tom holland also posted this to his
instagram and what he captioned this was
rather interesting but i'll talk about
that in just a bit i know a lot of
people want to know when this is going
to come out and there are two options we
don't have an official release time yet
although we do know that the fan event
is going to be taking place at 5 pm this
is pacific time that means the two
options for when this trailer could
release are either very early in the
morning tomorrow 6 a.m pacific time or
around then which is kind of a norm for
marvel studios however this is being ran
by sony or around 5 p.m tomorrow and i'm
actually assuming that it's going to be
around 5 p.m the reason being they are
having a very special event for the
release of the trailer i doubt they're
gonna show the trailer online before
they get a chance to show it to the fans
at the fan event that is specifically
for the showing of the trailer not to
mention this is kind of like how they
did the teaser trailer marvel studios
and sony usually released trailers
during the morning early in the morning
however for the teaser trailer they
didn't this is because they released it
at a major convention and sony had a
panel so they released a trailer there
first and it happened to be at night
looks like they're going to be following
kind of the same course they did last
time having an event at night and are
going to release the trailer right after
they show it to the fans at the event so
we're not sure how long the event is
actually going to be but i'm assuming
the trailer is going to drop between 5
p.m and 7 p.m pacific time so that is
the main window you need to look out for
be sure to subscribe and hit the bell so
you don't miss out when i post it have
those notifications turned on now let's
talk about what tom holland said when he
posted the new poster to his instagram
the caption for the poster was the
multiverse is real exclamation mark now
i know a lot of people can argue and say
that well this is for the villains that
are coming but i'm gonna go ahead and
say that this is tom holland giving us a
little bit of a wink saying that the
multiverse is real and the other two
spider-men are coming i think this is
our boy giving us a sign here i
definitely think he's hinting at the
other two spider-man but let's see if
sony and marvel tease the other two
spider-man in the trailer tonight i do
not think we're going to get a full
reveal however i'm hoping for a bit of a
tease that is somewhat clear perhaps
maybe some of their old music plane
perhaps their shadows let's hope for the
best here in the meantime let me know
how excited you are to finally get this
trailer tomorrow and let me know if you
think they should tease the other two
spider-man or not mention them at all
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below for live updates you
can follow me on instagram twitter and
tick tock and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof